last speaker for the day is Viet cheat
run is that roughly pronounced correctly
what is the correct pronouncement
Vietnamese name yes so the T you don't
really pronounce
well well yes my my real uh
second name is T and uh T is
okay so he will talk to us about random
walks on simplicial complexes and we'll
learn what has to do with epidemics
during this talk
thank you very much
so I'm really sorry about that but my
talk will of course it's motivated by
epidemics but you will not see very much
epidemics during this talk
so it's a work that we did in
collaboration with Lauren dekos form who
is at the Institute of mentally company
who is a
professor in the University result
effect where I work and the Han Zhang
who was a former PhD student of Lauren
so first I will uh show some motivations
but let's record some basic that way I
think that everybody knows these
notation so we will consider static
non-oriented random graphs and also
after
um
Synthesia complexes and
um the graph will have let's say n small
n vertices and edges will be a
non-oriented pairs but after that we
will sometimes also consider oriented
pair UV
uh with user starting of the edge and
the
um the idea of the edge the direction to
toward which The Edge is directly
adjacency Matrix will be G of course you
know guv is equal to one if you have an
edge between the vertices U and d and
you can also Define the degree of U by
looking at the line guv
so let me give sorry yes
so my motivation was the following
so I um
I heard the former work well with
colleagues where we studied the contact
tracing for HIV epidemics in Cuba and as
you see for instance this was the large
component of the of the of the data that
we had so it's a very large component
and
you don't see many things and one of the
questions that we were wondering was
asked this morning by uh jigani it was
um what kind of model do we put on grass
because depending on the network model
we have different uh
processes for describing how the
epidemic spread on this model on this
network
and unfortunately when we have real data
and we look into into it none of the
simple mathematical models that we have
uh
see the data so you can see that you
have a lot of Corrections between
vertices
but what we did is that to try to
understand more the structure which is
on the left we did a clustering so here
it's a modular modular narrative
clustering but we could have done also
spectral clustering and the clustering
it helps you to find groups of vertices
which are which are more strongly
connected to the other and
um
a few connections between the crystals
and once we did that so the left graph
becomes the right graph and in the right
graph what you can see
is that well you have colors the colors
they indicate for instance the
um one for HIV one important variable is
uh sexual orientation of individuals so
the red ones were more heterosexually
composed and the green ones were more
like men having sex with men
and what you can see that uh you have a
stratifications of colors all the red
ones are on the same side the green one
on the other side and we could link also
this to the edge of epidemics red
clusters are older clusters and we have
a propagation in time so epidemics was
introduced in Cuba by
um meet people coming from military
mission in other countries and and then
it spread in the countries and jump to
from military men to women and and then
to men having sex with men and so you
have a history that you can that you can
attend so the history also explains why
uh simple
Network structure doesn't match the data
and what we see that we have some big
clusters and when we try to see if the
big pressure can correspond to simple
mathematical models sometimes they do so
for instance in many bit cluster I try
to to to
infer the the degree distribution and
then to see whether we can consider that
vertices were connected at random or not
and sometimes it was the case sometimes
it was not the case but my conclusion
was that okay maybe we can do simple
models on some pressure and then try to
to assemble all the bricks
but still I had a remaining
um question which was can it is it
possible or although to have a more
more clear information on the topology
of the network because it's something
that is really important for
epidemiology and
when we deal about clustering so it
refers to connectivity so let me record
two basic definitions so you have the
laplation of the graph
which is the adjacent symmetrics minus
um The Matrix with the degrees in the
diagonal so let me draw a very simple
example
I have a one triangle here let's say one
two three
and one separate Edge four and five
so I record things that everybody knows
so if I write the adjacency Matrix so
one is connected to two and three so we
have something like this two is
connected to one and three and three is
connected to one and two
and here you have only zeros because
four and five are separate and we have
something like this okay so this is
adjacent symmetric G I subtract to eat
the degree distribution so minus 2 minus
2 minus 2
on the first block and on the second
block minus one minus one
in fact it's easy to see that the kernel
of this Matrix is a of Dimension two
okay you can find very easily the two
eigen Vector that spans the kernel of
this laplacian Matrix so of course you
have one one one and the second one is
you have
first block zero and second block one so
what you see is that
um the kernel of the LaPlace Matrix
one one basis that generates this kernel
is done by indicators of the vertices
which are in the same connected
component
and what is important so this is about
connectivity
uh it's a related also to clustering and
antennas it's related to the spectral
properties of the laplation Matrix here
and we see we know also that the
operation Matrix if you see it as an
operator as I showed here
it's also the generator of the random
walk that works on the graph it's a work
which starts from a Vertex let's say one
it chooses one of the Neighbors at
random so with probability one-half it
jumps to two and with probability one
half it jumps to three
Etc
so in fact we can we this is the
discrete time uh random work that we can
also look at to run a walk that weights
an exponential time let's say of uh Moon
one and after this exponential time
chooses one unable to grow to go to oh
sorry
each neighbor calls the vertex with uh
at rate one after an exponential time
and the first one to call is the one
that is visited
Okay so
um in the second project that we had
is also related to visiting this uh
these networks by random workers so when
you deal with um
sexually transmitted disease for
instance or with a management protons we
also look at people injecting drugs
uh
these things are are
sometimes people don't want to reveal
the true contacts or even the true
nature whether they are heterosexual or
homosexual and
of course you cannot do a database
saying this person takes drugs and and
has how many contacts and he has here
are the names so one one thing is to
explore complex Network we can just let
random workout
explosion and this is called a snowball
sampling or respondent driven sampling
methods all these things are related and
what does so so what are these three
letter acronyms which is ACV
yeah HTV is a hepatitis C virus and RDS
oh yes it's respondent driven sampling
oh s is really something something
sampling something
the idea is just that um people don't
want to reveal their real name but you
can give them like a coupon a small
small ticket and for instance if you
want you can give each individual three
tickets he gives them to his or her
contact and this contacts come and take
also an interview and so you can
reconstruct the draft you know exactly
who knows who without having the names
of people coming for instance
this is a roof idea and our question was
can we design uh can we think of other
way to explore a known Network by uh
spreading other kinds of workers on on
it okay for instance uh if we if we let
a random worker go we see that we will
have some somehow the LaPlace and
operator or a modification of it and we
will recover information on the
connectivity or at least clusters Etc
but there are also other things that we
want to to obtain for instance if you
have a very specific structure that is
here Circle this is not indicated by a
solar pressure Matrix
okay but uh from the topological point
of view the number of connected
component is what is called the Betty
number beta0 and you have also uh
topological indicator other Betty
numbers which are beta 1 beta2 that can
indicates the number of rules for
instance like this or cavities if you
look in higher Dimension Etc
so if you have just one graph of course
you can you can complexify it by saying
for instance here so this is a data from
Australian I forgot to to mention them
uh overall it's David rolls and
co-source and as you can see sometimes
you have clicks so when you have
three vertices connecting together you
can add a triangle to your graph if you
have a click of order four you can add a
data to try drawn Etc so you can
generate in this way uh higher
dimensional structure and now the
question is can we explore this higher
dimensional structure with random
molecules and what is the information
that is given
and the second the second thing is also
that for me when I discovered the topic
so
it's not published yet but uh it's uh
maybe soon but it's something that we
started several years ago it's just that
sometimes life is very slow and when I
discovered these structures I I'm as a
probabilistice I wanted some
probabilistic explanation of the ability
numbers or or some topological
quantities and so I I we I try here to
explain from a probabilistic way all
these um
notion that arise from topology and
geometry
so let me recall
um what is a simple Circle X so we can
look at the simplex
so Simplex is just a set of a case
impacts with a set of K plus one
vertices so
you can say a zero Simplex is just one
vertex if you look at uh one Simplex you
have two vertices so it's an edge okay
so what we do with graph is a
one-dimension line now now if you have a
triangle
so this is a three vertices so this is a
two Simplex okay
triangle is in two Dimension and if you
have a tetrade run so it's a three
Simplex Etc okay
you can go
you have two orientations for the cpcs
so these are so we will denote them by
plus or minus okay
so when you have a triangle in fact
the orientation of the triangle it it
gives an orientation on edges and if I
take the other orientation I will have
the other orientation on edges
and we call the face of uh a case
Simplex the K minus ones in PCS that are
obtained by uh taking out one vertex so
for instance if I have a triangle the
faces are the edges of this triangle
and the co-faces is uh is a reverse so
for instance the co-face of this Edge
are all the triangles that admit this
Edge as a a space
and the simplistic complex is a sum of
all these objects of the different
dimensions so vertices edges triangles
the triadron Etc
and the only constraint that we have on
simpler complex is that when we
deconstruct it we should have all the
elements in the simplest cell complex
that means that
if I have a K plus one uh Simplex in my
simplified complex all the faces should
be also in C
I I say it with other words if I have a
triangles the edge of the triangle
should be also in this complex as well
as the vertices of the triangles okay
you want something a bit hierarchical so
that when you deconstruct it all the
elements are also here
and so for
um
picture complex is uh denoted by C
so in the sequel I will you I will use
one example to illustrate what we say so
simple complex C is like a graph you
don't need to have all the edges okay
some are Somehow Here some are not here
um
it's a collection that satisfies only
that if you look at the faces they are
here provided higher structures here so
let's say we have one two three
four five
and what I so these are the edges you
see of course that some edges are
missing on my picture and I add also
these two triangles
and you see for instance that the h35 is
not on my online
and so this is my simple complex C and
for a given C I can look at all the
Simplex the case Simplex of this simple
complex so for instance if I look at a
there's two of C it's all the triangles
of my simpler complex here I have only
two I have uh let's say one two three
and I have also two three six
yeah
social complexes itself a breath
it's more than a graph it's uh you you
add a two three and girls the tradron
ETC if I look at if I look at S1 of C
if I look at S1 of C it's a set of edges
and if I look at the at the pair as zero
of C as one of C this is a graph okay if
I add S2 of C I have a graph plus
triangles Etc
yes exactly she said
okay hypercarf is not a simplexizer no
because you you don't need to have this
hierarchical inclusions
but uh that is it's close as well so
what is special that you're doing some
pressure complex I could have more
channels sale complexes I could have
four cycles and the faucet making the
four cycle maybe some cubes so you could
have very general circumflexes why are
you only looking at things which are
generated by triangles that I hate ones
and so on because
um we could do what you say this is
possible here's the only thing is that I
want to have a
you see if I if I go further I have
Detroit drone this is for
for the TC so if you do like this for
every number of vertices you have the
corresponding click click if you do like
a cube and then uh four cubes so for
some K you have no corresponding
structure that's the only reason why we
do but it's it would be possible
from an informative point of view I I
suspect that it could be have even more
but I I'm I'm not sure of that I I
discuss this later so let me give
um example of a simplified complicity
that interests us
so the church complex
sometimes to model the fact that you
have correlations between vertices you
can uh and this is something that we
will do later we you can try to put them
into a legend space where they have a
positions and if they are close they are
more likely to have edges
and what what you can do is that you can
take some
distance are positive and you say that
if you have um K plus 1 vertices for
which all the balls intersect then you
add the case syntax that corresponds so
for instance if you have two balls that
intersect you are sure you have an edge
if you have a third board that
intersects the intersection of the two
previous boards you have the triangles
Etc so this is if you vary all this it
gives you persistent normality right
exactly but here we
don't do that
um this structure is complicated because
you you see you have some conditions
that involves both so the geometry uh
has a very very important um important
word here but the rich details complex
is the same but more easy to to do so
what you do is that instead of looking
at the intersection of all the boards
you say that if you have all the edges
then you add the higher dimensional
structure so what I said before so when
you have a graph you add the clicks so
this corresponds to reefs bitter is so
you can have for instance three
individuals connected you add the
triangles if you have a fourth one that
connects to the three pull this one you
add the tetrade run whether the boards
intersect or not
and later because because things are
very complicated what we will do is we
will also resume to a triangulation of
the tourists and we'll see what we can
do with that
so when we have
um now we we need a bit of algebraic
formalism so we will call it China uh it
will be
um
it will be the span of CPAC synthesis
okay for instance uh it's uh here the
sum of uh all the Tau let's say
kcpcs with positive orientations and I
put uh I put a real number or complex
number let's say real in front of it why
do I do that so it seems a bit strange
at first but at some point I want to
describe also pass in my in my graph so
imagine I want to have
this path two three and three four I can
say that this is a chain
which is uh which is two three Plus
three four okay I can do things like
that and what happens is that imagine
that here I continue my path it's like
this and it can turn several times
and use several times the same Edge so I
want sometimes to put before an edge
away that is more than one maybe two or
three depending on on whether the past
uses several times a given Edge
okay
it will become more clearer in the
sequel I hope
so when you do this you have a vector
space if the original structure is
finite dimensional so you don't have any
difficulty in in
defining this
um you can Define also the norm that
corresponds if you have n vertices this
is like a finite dimensional Vector
space so you have the usual number that
say that the square of the norm is a sum
of questions to the square okay
uh so this is a hinder structure and you
can Define the Dual so the Dual are
linear functions but here because
everything is um is a finite dimensional
you can even uh you can even identify
the Dual c k with the K above with the
space of the chain the CK with a K below
okay
in any case there are isomorphic so
you you didn't tell us that
do you have duals in your complexes so
do you if you fix a dimension you would
consider the center of a tetrahedron
dual to it and uh no it's not the Dual
in this uh in this uh in this respect
it's really an algebraic dwell for
instance if I look at Edge let's say a
vertices let's say vertices okay the
jewel will be generated by the function
U star
such that U star V is equal to one if a
v equals U star is equals U or zero
otherwise
that you can you can do the same for but
it's not a kind of dual graph or drive
it's really algebraic drawer here
we are we have a boundary map so
boundary map it takes
sorry it takes a case a case simplex and
it it does this kind of uh so it goes
from CK to CK minus one so it takes a
case simplex and it gives you the K
minus one chain which is defined like
this so you subtract the vertex I and
put in the chain a weight minus one to
the power I
so let me
so we we by definition we can say that
if k equals 0 Delta zero is zero it's a
null uh application and we can check
that Delta K so Delta K plus 1 equals
from K plus one simply C is to K
syncreases and then to kcpcs to K minus
one synthesis and what we see that if we
compose these two ones they are zero so
let me give a very simple example
foreign
one two three so if I look at a Delta 2
of this triangle okay I I take out the
first vertex so it's minus
uh
so I take out the first vertex one so
it's minus two three then I take the
second uh
so it's
necessary then I take so this is vertex
0 I take out that X1 so it's minus one
three
yes exactly and I then I take out uh the
vertex three and it's plus one two
and then I apply data Delta 1 on top of
this
so it's a linear uh it's a linear
application okay what you can see is a
Delta one of two three is three minus
two well three the vertices
minus
here three minus one
and then plus
vertex 2 minus vertex one so it's a
chain it's a linear combination of
of the vertices and what you see that
each each one the two appears once with
minus and one twist plus so everything
simplifies
see I have minus and minus so it's plus
so everything simplifies and in the end
it's zero okay so this is something that
is well known in uh in homology so they
say that the image of Delta K plus 1 is
included into the kernel of Delta K and
they have this case homology Vector
space which is a kernel of uh Delta k
questioned it by image of Delta K plus
one okay so it seems very strange for us
but in fact we have a probabilistic
interpretation of this so that's what we
will uh I I will show just now
and the dimension of h k the K the
homology space is beta K so from
topology you know that beta K is the
number of cavities of dimensional of
Dimension K but we would like to
understand a bit more how well this
comes from
so let's take for instance k equals 0
okay so for k equals zero
uh look again so it's a kernel of Delta
zero Delta zero is a null application so
the kernel of Delta zero is all the
vertices V and then you look at image of
Delta one image of Delta one when you
take an edge UV
the the by Delta one you have V minus U
so the image of Delta 1 is the span of
all the the chains U minus V with u and
v edges of my simple complex
foreign you can say Okay I I take all my
vertices and I put an equivalence
relation that say that if I have a path
between these two vertices they are in
the same component so I can understand
that beta0 is a number of connected
components
and we want to do the same for beta 1
beta2 Etc so that's what we will do
um
that's important
okay so let me talk just before doing
the prologies probabilistic
interpretation let us consider
co-boundary application so we know how
to go from kcpex to K minus one C packs
but you can do the rebirth as well so
you take a function that acts on K minus
one C backs and you want to define the
coupon that read that excellent case
Simplex okay
so the way of doing is uh so this is we
didn't Advantage it already received
before but the co-boundary application
it acts on F by saying that if you look
at the image of some kcplex f acts on K
plus uh
FX on K minus one CPC so you have to
take out one vertex and you look at the
image of f
on this
and you combine all this with the minus
one to the power I depending on who you
have taken out okay and because uh these
are FR linear functions here so
everything is here you can see that uh
Delta J star of f
is also F applied to Delta k
of the case Simplex so you have a kind
of
visuality relation where you can invert
later on we will have like a scalar
products and you can use this as a joint
operators
so let let us give just an example to
understand this co-boundary map if you
look at Delta one of
data one style of f applied to the edge
visual V1 it is f of V1 minus F of v0 so
you can understand it as a flow okay
especially if you take F to B U star the
function that is equal one when you take
the dot X U and zero otherwise what you
see that if you look at Delta one star
of U star of The Edge UV you have minus
one because U is a vert is a vertex from
which unit that you leave
and if you look at data one star you
star vu it's one because here U is the
vertex at which you arrive okay and
otherwise it's you so Delta one star you
can you can interpret it as a kind of of
flow in what in what follows
okay so at this point we have a kind of
um
people into positions that like this
very much or this kind of diagrams
um so you have all the space CK I just
write them so that we can keep this in
mind later so you have the boundary
applications that Maps CK plus one into
CK CK and CK plus one CK sorry there are
they can be identified with a dual
okay here's the same
and and you have the co-boundary maps
that goes in the reverse Direction
and that uh that applies to a function
acting on kcpcs and gives you a function
that applies on K plus one cpcs
and so now you can you can Define
a kind of a higher order location so
they are defined like this so
um
the combinatorial location is given by
the sum of two operators the first one
so you start from K simplices
you go to k minus 1 ct6
so you start from K plus 1 cpcs you go
to kcpcs and then you go back to K plus
1 CPC so you start from CK plus one you
you
sorry I I
I did a mistake I
okay you apply first of course you apply
always first the right one so you you
apply Delta start K plus one so you
start from CK you go higher in dimension
that's why you have an arrow to the an
upward arrow and then when you are in
the higher Dimension you apply the
boundary maps that takes you back to CK
and for the lower location
you don't want the percent you first go
from CK to
CK minus 1 by applying the boundary math
and then you take the co boundary map
that Maps you again
to a case increases
okay what are the and there is a
combinatorial hostile and from the
topology that says that if you
look at
um
at CK
the the space of chains
made of TK dimensional syntax so it's
the image of Delta K plus one plus the
image of Delta K Star Plus the kernel of
the
of the combinatorial adaptation and
because you look at the dimension uh
beta was the dimension of h k in fact
you can show that
HK is a
has the same Dimension as the kernel
here
and beta is also the dimension of the
kernel of this location
you can now forget everything that are
on these two lines what you just what I
wanted just to use is that this
operators LK in the same way as in the
spectral crystalline we look we look at
the kernel of the LaPlace and Matrix now
we are looking at the kernel of this
combinatorial locations foreign
Delta one Delta one star
so G is not no longer here the adjusted
symmetrics but G is the Matrix of the
boundary map do you see if I write here
or maybe
thank you so if I look at the boundary
map
I have for instance my vertices two
three
Etc and here I have my edges one two
three
I try to do the same Matrix in case I'm
I'm lost after that but
I can list all the all the
edges
tier one is uh appears in
one two
I will take a minus one because it's the
ego of the vertex of the oriented vertex
and in three one I take a one because
it's the vertex to which I go okay
if I look at one two here two is a the
text which I arrived so I have one like
this and then I have only zeros and for
two three the same here I have minus one
and here we have one Etc so I have a
matrix like this and if
you look from a matrix
representation of this uh of this
formula so you have LG with G times G
transpose
so what happens when I look at the for
instance the line three and the column
two
so the only time where the line so
column two is also the line two here of
the column two of G transpose is a line
two of t so the only time when you have
both on trees that are non-zero
is when you have an The Edge two three
or three two okay and then the product
is minus one and uh when you have um
when you are on the diagonal
so if I look at one one in fact whatever
I have minus one or one when I do the
product it's press one so on the
diagonal I will have the degree of
of the vertex okay so when do you look
at how what
how you can write l0 so you see that you
have my minus uh so for U star it's a
minus uh
yes it's minus one when V is different
from U
and it's the degree so in fact I should
maybe have a I have a minus yes that I
didn't solve but you saw it from your
place so it's minus the sum of V Star so
this corresponds to this minus one
plus degree of U times U star
and what you can see that this can be
interpreted as Delta 1 of UV
the the thing here is that I just wanted
to show that by taking here I apply the
operator l0 to U star you can also apply
l0 to other function s maybe I can skip
the computation and what you see that
minus l0 is the generator of the random
work that goes from U to V at rate one
when you and you are moved by an edge
okay
[Music]
your definition of code chain your
coefficients uh Lambda
V comes from the the real numbers is
there any reason why you take it because
you could have taken any ring or field
if you want right
my assumption is just a function that uh
takes some uh let's say uh vertices or
sure okay sure but in your definition of
code chain I could have taken
the coefficients Lambda not coming from
R but maybe just F2 yes yes or any ring
or yes any advantage that's true and and
one possibility is a to take for
instance Z over 2z so it's always zero
one yes yes you have to record yeah yes
exactly so what is the advantage of
having R and we took R because um that
was um what we did but yes other
possibilities are possible as well
because it's more combinatorial right
zero one is there after that we want to
take the limit when you have a large
graph and that's maybe but taking F2
would have been easier so thanks
foreign
sorry I'm a little confused about the
linearity here so l0 of u v is the same
as l0 of v u but UV is
-1 Vu so l0 is not linear is it right
so tell me again so l0 of u v is minus
one yes and it's also eligible of uh of
Vu so if I swap the two vertices it's
also yes so l0 is not a linear operator
uh
no no sorry I I I'm sorry I think it's
not uh as you of you if you take uh
if you take
it
and so there is like a different Matrix
for different UV yes oh no no I'm sorry
this is the question UV of The Matrix l0
oh okay thank you okay so it's not a
zero acting on the oh no no this is just
Azure is a matrix and sorry I I Now
understand your question so this is the
entry uh line U and column V of l0 right
so and and you put all these coefficient
and um thanks sorry of course I say also
a mistake because I was thinking that I
wanted it to be linear but uh of course
you can take transpose it gives you the
same Matrix
everything is fine
okay so for in fact the what I present
here is um not not new because uh
there's a quite largely trying to
understand uh the combinatorial location
so for instance here I I mentioned uh
the main references that we have so they
were meteorology and steenbergen and
passenger still horizontal but maybe I
missed uh
or the other Outsource but
the in this paper they try to give
probability interpretation as well of
the combinatorial depression and it's a
bit difficult because I have shown you
only the good part the upward location
and the upward person has
um the feature of the generator of a
random walk so I have shown here for l0
that you can do it for the other one if
you look at the downward location it's
not so clear so for instance
um
if I don't mix the two references they
they need to have a random walk with
death or bronze sheet so it's not so
easy and you can interpret also the both
operators separately
but then you have to to merge them
together so it's not it's always a
non-trivial uh non-trial thing so what
we did here that we tried to propose
another work and we don't want to deal
with well
if we are interested in the Spectrum
what we can show is that the spectrum of
the two operators are the same so
for that we need only to interest
ourselves in the a poor other person
okay
so we try to find a realm work for which
the generator is a quarterly present and
that stays in the kernel of the downward
lap lesson so that if it stays in the
corner of the downward location
this term will disappear
okay so what is the corner of the
downward location it's it's
um if you look at the triangle
so if you look at the chain for instance
a sequence of edges for which
there is no boundary with vertex okay
the the the location will be zero so
what we do is that we will consider the
random work on the space of chains the
space of change is the kernel
of uh
of the boundary uh of the boundary
application Delta K
so for instance if you look at k equals
2 you have a surface without holes on it
but if you look at k equals one what we
have is that we have a path
for which the starting point and the
ending points are the same okay and what
we will do is that we have we have a
chain valued
Markov chain and continuous time and
each time we want we we will um
for instance here there is a triangle I
take this triangle and I can add a
triangle and I have a new path in this
way okay so I have a change value a
cycle valued imagine a k equals one I
have a cycle valued Markov chain and it
explores the Simplicity complex by using
the triangles as a way to go
so
to to make things more precise just look
at the usual random Runner mode usual
random work this is a generator of the
usual work you go from X to Y when you
have an edge between X and Y then Y in
terms of change you can also write that
it is x minus the boundary of the edge x
y
okay and what is this boundary of h x y
it is the image of Delta one so you see
that in the homological space that we
had just before the kernel of Delta K
constanted by the image of Delta K plus
one in fact the kernel is a space in
which we take our values
and the image is give us the transition
of our Markov chain okay so this
homological uh writing with questions is
it's very natural if we think of State
space and transition uh of the Markov
chain so if we go to the chains so the
the kernels of Delta 1 are all the
cycles and uh transitions are given by
triangles so if I take one triangle the
boundary of the triangles
it gives me the three edges because I
take minus so I subtract the edges that
was common to the cycle and I add
instead the two new edges
we can show a lot of things so we can
show that of course the generator is LK
but uh because we are in the kernel of L
downwards so LK upwards for these Cycles
are the same as as LK downwards it's a
strong Mark of chain
maybe I should think to
um
the
XT remains in the same homology class as
x0 by construction because you visit
only if you start in an equivalence
class you cannot jump to the other
equivalence class
and and that's why we can think of it as
the spectral pursuing where
when you are in some component of the
corner you stay in the same connected
component and you don't jump to the
other one
we have some difficulties except if we
take like the question in F2 as you say
because even in the triangulation that I
showed before
let me do this quickly
things can become very degenerate so we
took three angulations we could do that
on the whole space but we do this on the
we do this on the on the Taurus to have
things compact for later purposes and
what can happen
is that you have a path like this then
it goes down and because it's a tourist
it go it it comes
from the other side again and nothing
prevented to merge again and here you
have this bus which is used twice and in
fact you can Loop like this and you can
have a path that is used an infinite
number of times when you want okay so
it's like you have a chain and suddenly
you do a lot a lot of Loops like this
and then you go out
these things make that um
it's a bit tricky sometimes especially
uh for later purpose when we want to
rescale this kind of random works if you
have a kind of things like this it's
very degenerate to so showing tightness
for instance it's not so easy
but
when we have a finite number of
K plus 1 cpcs provided we start in a in
um let's say with a chain cycle with a
finite number of edges
okay we can show that this Markov chain
is uh has a unit well it's agodic and it
has a unique environment measure by and
for this in fact what we prove is that
we have um
[Music]
we are we show what is called uh
when we have a very simple Japanese
function which is the normal and we have
this kind of uh of inequality that that
um
very famous in the main entry this work
for instance and that I'm sure that uh
this this is a leopard function you have
a negative question in front of it so
you cannot go to Infinity where you
cannot escape and uh and it gives that
the macro chain has unique environment
measure
okay maybe I can disappear or maybe I
was a bit too fast
I can maybe skip this and discuss this
with those are interested just after
as I say so this is a proof of of the
inequality I was just showing it's a
then
um
she has a she tried to use these workers
to have a statistical
um
statistical simulations but also
statistical applications so what you did
is for instance she simulated networks
with the rules and what she discovers is
that the unique environment measure when
she looked at it it discovers the the
boundary of the rules so it's not
exactly
um
the runner Markov chain that that we
have she she did a kind of uh simulated
annulation using this Markov chain to
have this but she can't show this kind
of things and to conclude I just want to
say some words
naturally that when you have a Markov
chain there are two things that you want
to do first is to try to see whether
what is its behavior in long time does
it has a individual measure Etc and
second thing is to renormalize and
rescale this from the work to see if you
have a Continuum limit because sometimes
things are very complicated on discrete
structures and they become more simple
when you have continuum
for a Continuum you cannot stay in a
very abstract space so that's why we
look at geometric graphs I just say this
as a teaser so we can if we have a
geometry graph it means that our
vertices they have a geometric position
let's say in the Taurus for instance and
then we rescape the random work so it's
not so easy we can we can look at
convergence of generators convergence of
generators is a
okay it's not simple but it's something
which has a been studied a lot
especially in informatics or machine
learning literature you have a lot of
convergence of chip of different
generators
to have tightness as well it's a bit
more complicated but I just want to
conclude with this so we can show
convergence to a an operator which is
called LaPlace
operator
and this is a kind of of limiting object
that we want to have so you see you have
the cycle the cycle is not necessary
just one Loop because what can happen is
that your cycle can break into into two
cycles
okay if you have one cycle and then you
have a bottleneck and then you subtract
the triangle of the bottleneck so then
your cycle can become two like two
bubbles of course these two bubbles I
can merge again and as long as I say the
same homology class but if this is the
case by construction so
in the in the limiting object you can
you can have several uh connected
components and what you are what
what we would like is to understand a
bit more this kind of images that that
we have but this is a bit far from
epidemic the small form or mathematical
perspective and if I conclude in one
sentence with epidemic
purposes again uh one thing that I would
like to do but it's not at all uh even a
the United so but for contact tracing
you know we are it's like we have been
exploring the graph by asking for the
neighbors and for what we did in France
for instance well certainly but what
people did in France is that they
they uh the social workers they go and
try each contact one by one like
randomly without any uh other methods
than just there's a list and we have to
ask our people of the list and imagine
that for some epidemics you want to go
fast for instance if the people give you
10 contacts
well you have no other means than just
either asking the whole 10 contacts or
saying okay I take three or four at
random but if the people say I know A
and B but I know that A and B also are
friends so this gives you a 300 so my
idea was if we have a bit more
information but this is not completely
absolute you like you know if your
friends know each other or not this is
something that you usually know so if
you give this extra information
um and if you do contact tracing by
using a higher dimensional structure do
you go faster in discovering the shape
of the network and and the the places
where the Venus can propagate or not
well thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much uh questions
thanks for your talk
um I had a question about there was a
point where I think it was towards the
end so you went through it quickly but
you said we find the identity of these
holes we find the boundary of the holes
yes
um is this related to so I guess can you
provide intuition on how you do that is
it related to like the key chains that
are in the kernel of this Hutch yes so
she starts with Cycles at random and she
let them move and after that she looks
at
um did I say in giant measure so she can
look at edges how many times they have
been occupied by the chain
so of course if you are far from the
rules you may be visited once or twice
but the chain spends more time on the
road because it it's like a reflected on
them so that's how she she can find this
at the end that these edges um have
different roles but the chain can also
have non-zero support away from the
holes right yes yes so I guess she
averages over several yes because if she
it's a good point that you that you
raise
um
your your change it stays in a connected
component so for instance if the chain
is around this point so should start
from this red chain here you can never
discover the the second one okay you
have to start another chain around this
hole to find this hole
you could have a
around the whole but have support
overlapping support in the regions that
are not around yes
yes that could have been
I I admit I I have not look in detailing
in our coding because she was a student
of my collaborator but I can
we I if you ask me I can give you
precisions
more questions
whoever gets it has to carry it around
oh see that was
maybe not an optimization so my question
so thank you this was really interesting
yet so a question that I have is do you
have sense about how quickly do these
chains converge you know if you if you
do this random walk
how how quickly can you get to the
stationary distribution so when when you
have the
when you when you have this kind of
identity here
you can also have exponential
convergence rate but because we are here
in back these some people will tell you
that this exponential convergence rate
is not true and you might have a cutoff
but I am I'm not okay but now with this
I haven't looked into this kind of stuff
okay so so you don't know what's what's
sort of the the size of Lambda M here
right
what's what's what's uh well in fact in
fact
this is the third theoretical so you
should know that it should at least
converge exponentially fast but if you
wanted the the Lambda M you you should
know the Matrix LK and in applications
sometimes you don't know the whole uh no
no but I thought maybe you you run an
example you know
I don't I didn't investigate this okay
all right thank you
like so I don't know anything about this
stuff it was an excellent talk I really
enjoyed it my questions are kind of
about the last slide when you kind of
talked about how you could use this for
epidemics and the LaPlace belletrome
part so
um I I kind of if you wanted to do
something like spectral clustering but
using this right so I guess first of all
what does that result that you uh
derived based on the convergence to that
up does it does it tell you about what
kind of data you need for it to be
embeddable well like is it you know like
in the original
um case for spectral clustering you know
that it should have some kind of
manifold setup yes yeah well
um I'm not sure that uh the rescaling
would be useful for
clustering okay but um indeed the idea
is that for instance uh on for some data
you might the graph my conduction for
instance through manifold as you say and
uh the and the for instance he has a
tourist because it's a triangulation of
the tourists and then the the market in
contagious to a diffusion on this
manifold for which you have also tools
to study it but
the use of of this for clustering I I
don't know if it gives any result or not
okay more questions
well let let me ask for the follow-up
question on this is a sort of so in
general if we had a random walk on some
graph and it converges to some manifold
you would expect it converters to some
kind of brown emotion or so on that
manifold
what would be the analog of this higher
dimensional Brownian motions how should
I think of them yes so it's well the
simulation is the this image here and
and uh so it's um
we have the generator of the of this
process so on linear functionals like
let's say so linear functionality now
the path is uh like continuous path and
the functional is integrals of
differential forms along this path so
for this the genetic response exactly to
the location and aqua which is in
differential form given by by this
so when you apply to a function Phi you
have something that combines the
derivatives
but then
um
is it like some Loop process studied by
some people or related to other
I suspect there might be some but for
the moment I
okay
okay well I think we Dove deserved some
parties so we have our welcoming party
which is from four to five I'll see you
I think it's outside I'm not sure
actually just
evaluate seats either I think it would
probably be just out here